on va passer à un tout autre sujet à
présent les fermes de Gally organise un
grand job dating ce samedi 25 mars il
aura lieu au sein du magasin de
Saint-Cyr l'école de 10h à 14h pour en
parler avec nous pour nous grand sel
bonsoir alors vous êtes le responsable
de la communication et de l'événementiel
pour l'enseigne à Saint-Cyr l'école
quelles sont les postes qui seront pour
voir quels sont les domaines qui sont
qui sont à pourvoir donc on a une très
grande diversité de postes à pouvoir il
y a plus d'une cinquantaine de postes
qui sont à pourvoir sur les métiers qui
sont au cœur du jardin du paysage et de
la nature et ça à travers une très
grande diversité de contrats il y a des
postes en CDI qui a des postes en CDD on
recherche des saisonniers il y a des
stages qui sont proposés donc une très
grande diversité de poste donc 50 postes
c'est c'est énorme c'est habituel aux
fermes de Gally
est une entreprise qui compte quelques
centaines de salariés donc c'est une
entreprise qui se développe donc il faut
qu'on puisse pour voir j'allais dire
tous tous les postes qui se qui se
créent et puis les les gens qui qui
partent également il faut les remplacer
donc on a régulièrement oui pas mal de
pas mal de postes à pouvoir c'est des
postes qui peuvent être très différents
sur des métiers du du paysage donc c'est
à dire des métiers qui visent à embellir
les entreprises aussi bien les jardins
d'extérieur que ramener du végétal au
sein de l'entreprise donc où il y a des
postes à pouvoir en création
c'est-à-dire la réalisation de chantier
ou en entretien ce qu'on appelle dans
notre jargon de l'entretien c'est-à-dire
des des jardiniers qui vont passer pour
tailler entretenir arroser tous les
végétaux qu'on a mis en place
chez nos clients il y a des postes à
pourvoir au sein du magasin donc aussi
bien dans le secteur du végétal où on
recherche des pépiniéristes des vendeurs
de végétaux c'est le printemps depuis
deux jours donc on a enfin le soleil qui
revient et les conditions propices à
remettre les pieds dans son jardin ou
entretenir son balcon sa terrasse et on
va venir vouloir embellir tous ces
espaces là donc on recherche du monde
sur ce secteur là également on a au sein
du magasin des fermes de Galli un espace
de produits du terroir en circuit court
on recherche également des des salariés
pour venir mettre en rayon conseiller la
clientèle vendre nos produits on va
avoir bientôt l'ouverture de la
cueillette l'accueillette de Gally et
donc là on recherche des postes de
saisonniers également voilà à la
production ou bien également pour faire
du Conseil et au niveau des casques donc
effectivement au niveau des fermes de
Galilée il y a beaucoup de postes pour
voir pourquoi est-ce que vous organisez
ce grand job dating c'est un peu inédit
c'est la première fois au sein du
magasin que ça se fait c'est la première
fois on doit ce qu'on a souhaité faire
ce samedi prochain c'est de d'accueillir
les gens qui sont à la recherche
sur ces secteurs du jardin du paysage ou
de la nature au sein même du magasin de
manière à ce qu'ils puissent voir
vraiment l'environnement dans lequel ils
vont travailler il y a bien sûr l'équipe
RH des ressources humaines qui sera
présente mais il y aura également des
salariés donc c'est l'occasion de vivre
un petit peu l'expérience en
avant-première de rencontrer de
rencontrer ses futurs collègues donc on
s'est dit que
le fait de pouvoir accueillir des
candidats potentiels in situ sur le
magasin ça peut permettre de vraiment
prendre un petit peu la température et
voir comment est-ce que ça se passe
l'ambiance qui règne donc il va y avoir
des entretiens il faut que les candidats
viennent avec avec un CV
qui qui viennent échanger avec avec les
salariés avec l'équipe des ressources
humaines et on va faire ça de manière
très sympathique et essayer de faire
vraiment toucher du doigt les jobs qu'il
y a à se saisir chez nous est-ce qu'il y
a un profil pour travailler aux femmes
de Galilée des valeurs peut-être à avoir
fortes on est sur des milieux qui
touchent le vivant le végétal donc il
faut avoir une attirance pour pour le
vivant le
vivant c'est pas comme un crayon comme
un portable comme une boîte de conserve
on peut pas la laisser sur sur une
étagère et sans s'en occuper donc il
faut avoir de l'attirance pour ce milieu
là et une attirance pour la nature est
passionné du de son métier on est
vraiment des l'ensemble des salariés de
Noël ils sont des gens souvent très
passionnés et alors comment ça va se
passer concrètement les gens arrivent
avec leur CV et leur lettre de
motivation mais ils vont être enfin quel
est le nombre de personnes qui vont
pouvoir accueillir les demandeurs
d'emploi Comment comment est-ce qu'ils
vont être accueillis il doit y avoir un
gros sonnerie il va y avoir une dizaine
de personnes en permanence qui seront
présents au sein du magasin l'objectif
d'avoir en fonction de l'influence des
discussions en One to One avec avec les
candidats expliquer présentés
précisément les postes qui qui sont pour
voir essayer de voir comment est-ce
qu'on peut faire match la Tyros d'un
candidat à vaca un poste à pourvoir
échanger avec lui lui expliquer très
concrètement en quoi va consister ce
poste lui faire éventuellement
rencontrer un salarié qui réalise déjà
ses missions là de manière à ce que le
candidat
ne se projette pas que virtuellement
dans dans le métier mais puisse voir de
manière très concrète et puis vivre
l'environnement dans lequel il va
travailler donc il y aura à la fois
des personnes de l'équipe des ressources
humaines et également des salariés qui
sont en poste de manière à pouvoir
pas uniquement j'allais dire juger les
candidats d'une manière traditionnelle
sur un CV une lettre de
[Musique]
de voir quand on est dans des processus
classiques de recrutement en tout cas si
vous êtes intéressé le job dating aura
lieu samedi prochain à la ferme de Gally
de Saint-Cyr-l'École de 10h à 14h 50
postes sont à pourvoir alors n'oubliez
pas votre CV